la gestion des déchets justement un
casse-tête pour tout métropole et son
président réduit vendredi avec à ses
côtés une nouvelle gouvernance qui
intègre la ville centre Frédéric cogis
se voit profilé devant lui voit ce
profilé devant lui le mur des ordures
ménagères plus de 300000 tonnes à
traiter et d'ici 2029 il faudra faire
sans l'enfouissement les explications
avec Clémence dosc
que faire des déchets ménagers les
300000 tonnes produits chaque année sur
le département sont enfouis ou incinérés
mais plus pour longtemps les trois sites
de traitement principaux vont tour à
tour fermer comme le site de chance au
préloches au 31 décembre 2023 à la
métropole on assure prendre le dossier
en main et travailler sur une unité de
production d'énergie verte la solution
technique l'emplacement pour une unité
traitement peut être trouvée assez vite
après il y aura de toute façon
l'étang des études et le temps de de
faire accepter par par les services de
l'État ce nouvel outil d'abord il faut
faire oeuvre de pédagogie pour expliquer
réellement ce que c'est aujourd'hui un
UP parce que voilà il y a aussi des
représentations il y a des techniques
qui ont évolué des technologies qui ont
évolué quelle commune accueillera cette
unité pour l'ancien indice président
Jean-Luc Gaillot convaincre un maire et
sa population ne sera pas chose aisée un
conteneur à vert c'est difficile de
l'implanter donc imaginez
un incinérateur puisque ça devient ça
redeviendrait à la mode alors que
c'était la pire des abominations en 2001
c'est quasiment impossible à implanter
sauf un maire énergie que déterminé qui
cédrat pas aux pressions qui seront
considérables de son côté le président
de la métropole est confiant un outil de
60000 tonnes doit avoir le jour pour
régler le problème la Métropole va
prendre ses responsabilités avant fin
2023 un lieu sera dédié à cela et on
entamera la construction d'un
up dans cette métropole j'ai dit
carrément la fin du mandat il y aurait
vraiment plus que des études on en
serait au stade opérationnel je respecte
cet engagement que j'ai pris auprès de
mes collègues la promesse sera-t-elle
tenue à temps pour épargner le
porte-monnaie des habitants une hausse
de la taxe ordures ménagère est prévue à
l'horizon 2025